one of Apple's shortest events was all
about the small things
the tech giant debuted a new smaller
iPhone called the SE it's new but not so
much think of it as the little cousin of
the iPhone 6s in terms of capability and
performance except it looks like its
uncle the iPhone 5s the size dives
nicely with tiny hands and shallow
pockets this new iPhone starts at just
$399 with no contract and it ships on
March 31st the iPad pro is also
downsizing with Apple now offering a
nine point seven inch version of the
high-end tablet it packs the same power
as its 12 point 9 inch big brother but
it's far more easy to carry around
despite the smaller screen the new iPad
pros display has a new feature Apple's
calling true tone for ambient sensors
measure the ambient light in the room to
adjust the brightness and color
temperature of the display as you might
expect the protag comes with a big price
tag this new tablet will start at five
hundred ninety nine dollars for the 32
gigabyte model or seven hundred $49 for
the 128 gigabyte and a new offering 899
for the 256 gigabyte it goes on sale
March 24th and ships March 31st it comes
in four colors including that tasty rose
gold finish iOS 9.3 is now available for
download the update extends the reach of
3d touch protects your Notes app with
touch ID and our favorite new feature
makes reading in bed easier on the eyes
the new night shift mode adjusts the
brightness and color temperature of the
display depending on what time of day it
is after sunset it shifts the color
temperature of the screen from cooler
blue hues to warmer orange ones the idea
is that these color schemes work a lot
better with your circadian rhythms
meaning you might sleep better as a
result on the less exciting side there
were no hardware upgrades for the Apple
watch just a reduction in price the
watch now starts at $299 there are also
some new bands for it including a 90s
throwback NATO style woven fabric bands
and neon colors here's a mind-blowing
fact over a billion Apple devices are
currently in use worldwide with that in
mind
Apple has pushed hard to be more
sustainable the company claims 93%
it's facilities worldwide are now
running on renewable energy Apple also
introduced us to Liam a robot designed
specifically to pick apple products
apart piece by piece to make sure every
last component is recycled and reused to
keep Liam busy Apple will pay for us
customers to ship their old devices for
total but precise destruction